hi this is sal sally i'm a client
solutions director with dell
technologies
based in austin texas i work with a lot
of clients in the area of cyber security
protection against ransomware hacking
and
incident response
in the past i used to have to depend on
subject matter experts
to
delve deeper into the conversation to
uncover potential areas of opportunity
with the customer
and also
cover the breadth of
solution sets that were possible
about six months ago i decided to enroll
in the postgraduate program in cyber
security from simply learn offered in
conjunction with mit
because i wanted to be able to improve
my technical knowledge in cyber security
and also be able to serve my customers
better in terms of having those
meaningful conversations and uncovering
the right opportunities and the
potential solutions
i'm very pleased with uh the program at
simplylearn because of the quality of
the content
as well as
the fact that they have
excellent professors and teachers which
have practical experience along with the
right kind of people who are attending
from all over the world that can
positively contribute to the quality of
the education simply learn is a great
brand and mit
is second to none in terms of technical
education and the both of them together
have a winning combination
as a result of my course i'm having much
more meaningful conversations with
customers and more opportunities with
dell will open up in terms of leadership
as well
my advice to fellow learners is take the
plunge invest in yourself the pandemic
has given us an opportunity to have more
time available use it wisely
upskill your knowledge and your
education and it will pay off
in the long run and simply learn is a
great platform it does take a lot of
commitment of time and effort so you
need the discipline but in the end it
pays off